how about your boy connor is about to
fight manny pacquiao bro he's just
following floyd mayweather at this point
let's just talk about it but that's a
good fight though
really yeah i think it's a worse fight
for connor than floyd is
wait why could you think pacquiao is
going to stop him pacquiao's in the race
dog pacquiao just beat keith thurman
like less than a year but he's [ __ ]
thurman yeah and his fighting
style like it's a problem you think so
what tommy you really think well hold on
pacquiao is shorter than floyd
mayweather can we get that out the way
and connor
connor was towering over floyd so
imagine what he does with pacquiao how
tall is connor
we got about six foot right yeah six
foot i apologize
is it real live eleven on the way i'm
five eleven five five
eight what that's that's wicked that's
google though that's wikipedia
and what says floyd's 5 8 which is full
of [ __ ] that thank you see i'm saying
that no hell no
everywhere stilts you know it has to i
just i feel like stylistically just
manny's a tougher man you talk about an
aggressive knockout artist
i'm with you
it's either that or fight khabib or some
of these other [ __ ] like dude
fight man and get paid really gsp
gsp is listed at 510 but they looked
pretty much the same
story when gsp was trading in wild card
uh it's the nicest guy
uh i sparred him when he was the wild
card yeah because that's a hot take
no he's super friendly are you super
afraid yeah like yo he was i was hitting
him he was like oh good shot i was like
shut the hell up
todd is nice ass hello ty there's nice
commentary in the ring
i guess yeah that's a good fight though
four or four i'm talking about
money-wise yeah yeah yeah
is it a lot of money yeah generally 100
something like that do you like this
make 100 million
you know like i like i like it for
connor i like that i like connor as a
person i support him whatever he wants
to do
yeah i'm a fan oh i like that he's
getting paid because a lot of guys they
when they're done like you know a lot of
you guys are [ __ ] man you know how
fighting's a nightmare so it's like some
of your favorite fighters ranked in the
top 10 for years like they retire they
got nothing
what do you do work at the [ __ ] ufc
gym what are you gonna do
hold mids yeah so for connor it's like
dude get paid
whatever whatever you got to do to make
the most money possible do that
i don't even [ __ ] what only fans
whatever it is
get paid my [ __ ] damn these guys aren't
paid i got an idea
this wait are you paid yeah boxes are
paid
hold on hold up only certain boxes are
paid yeah
the majority aren't well yeah well like
only only the top top
upper echelon are paid but like what
about like a mid level
no no hell no i the world champion i
know this guy chris van herden who
the white guy uh south african copy them
close though um you know talking about
world champion
you know he's holding myths when doing
personal training really
yeah it's like boxing people think
boxing
the like they look at floyd mayweather
and the manny pacquiao did that you know
and then
the wilders and the tyson fury's but the
majority of them ufc makes better money
than the
like the middle of the ufc guy makes way
better money than boxer
boston [ __ ] name a mid-level boxer
go you look at the card there's like the
main event and then it's just all
whoever's the only page so you have to
work your ass off just to get to
anything correct anything to make money
and there's no sponsorship
no it's not not at all unless you're a
top top dog like
less than one percent make money with
sponsorship-wise you'll see at least
those guys are more well-known
you know because you know you know what
you know what it is
boxing has way too many belts that can
be a hot tape boxing has too many weight
classes wait clap but but everybody's a
champion how is
this guy a champion and that guy's a
champion and then that guy like bro we
don't even know who the real champ
of that weight class is i get what you
the box only promotes like six guys
which is only like legit like walking
the streets like if we were postmates
right now
their world champions could deliver my
[ __ ] churros we didn't know who they
are
you like churros love them and that's
and you know what i'll be like yo
that delivery was world champion speed
come on bro i'm with him because i'm in
here both feel so i gotta give them both
compliments
yep come on but when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just brought
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son